hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play lone
survivor once again sorry for the delay
I really have been wanting to get back
to this but uh I've just been busy with
other things but I'm gonna finish this
right here right now and also I just
stocked up on ammo for those blue pills
that I got before and now I need to
figure out what in the world I'm
supposed to do I think I need to go up
or when I go out into this side I need
to go right and then I'm gonna blam I've
pretty much foregone who's that up bone
I pretty much oh hi I can hide here wait
a minute I don't have to shoot him in
the balls I can just go around him ah
this is so much easier
what is this cozy corner convenient is
this that store what do i what you do
what wait a minute oh no wait no this is
the UH oh by the way I discovered that
in uh in the ammo shop that I could
actually move while I was hiding which
would have been an incredibly useful
thing to notice because I actually went
behind something it would have been
lovely to be able to do that like back
when I was facing all sorts of other
enemies I handle me I gotta find out
what's going on in here
yeah you want some cash man there's some
cash right by that register ignore the
rotting meat on the ground you wouldn't
want that no no you wouldn't want that
wow wow oh
sodas grunting I'm so disgusting hey
what oh I see oh I see I see how this is
mom I gotta get the right one to go for
it no not you you already ate man oh ah
ah gross man so gross
oh wait you gonna be like that why am I
even here
why aren't I blowing these guys in the
face ah get out of my way I've had it up
to here with your Bologna Oh
whoa whoa whoa why is he moving why is
he moving I'm gonna have to I'm gonna
have to blame him I'm gonna blame him
get ready to be blamed
who's gonna been badly because I got Wow
what no oh no you don't yep no no what
are you doing
show them your dick no really whoa whoa
did you see what that one on the other
side just dead showed its face to me
boom BAM Jackie yeah that's right oh
yeah who the best who the best probably
not me because of how many people I've
killed
well there's some food in here
you a sleepy cat comic that guy likes
those wait didn't someone say that if I
put rotting meat in the box no that
didn't work at all
nevermind I'm out of here cuz this was a
huge waste of time this was an
exorbitant waste of time I'm gonna
continue on my merry way as I tried to
find what ago
mo awesome I'd like 50 50 bullets per 40
sorry I had 50 before I serve lamin guys
that still doesn't sound right
another sleepy cat comic lovelies does
that go the dark alleyway huh kind of
shady and green huh I'd wear woo
this is very very useful why did I not
realize that there were more locations
with which I could have snuck behind
guys oh you son of a [ __ ]
there ain't no wood maybe there is oh ha
ha hee why don't you move your fat butt
oh yeah well what happened to this one
it's a body there's something in its
chest yeah pull it right out wire
cutters I got a car battery and wire
cutters cuz I'm some kind of
kleptomaniac here wait what just
happened I heard some yeah that that
wasn't there before why suddenly music
is it time to jazz it up over here I
just remember the last time I was here
in music was in that one freaky deaky
situation and I I don't want to be in
that situation again just saying just
supers day old building think it's a
cafe or wise something out of the
previous era some faraway place ruined
inside anyway why'd you bother
if you were just gonna be a negative
Nancy there's so many places to hide
there's so many places to hide oh this
isn't good Wow Wow whoa you're gonna get
Blaenau that hurts that weights that
really hurts
what did it spew at me you you you if I
need to eat something they gave me no
choices ooh
tena pickle I love pickles pickles are
like my favorite mmm delicious
more ammo what are they stocking me up
for something oh no what would I need
hide their good health tonic pick up a
crowbar one of these ever not come in
handy good good observation there guy
but you still are talking to yourself
all crazy kooky like all right let's see
wait a minute what is that really it how
do I get down to the thing over there
there's like a location down in the
bottom left but how do I get there
there's a question mark in the building
no that was where the boxes is question
mark in that back alley why I'm gonna
find out no no no no none on this one
this dumb those question mark no wait no
wait that's what I just got right I
don't need with why I'm so confused
dingus this game is very not giving
closing this if that's a word I just
made it everybody use that from now on
not giving clues Ingush when a game does
not give its intent properly and leaved
you confuzzled Hey
all right stop looking at me like that
Hey hey fatso tubby you go get some
dears I still wonder if these are
zombies or something I'm just getting a
good look at ya hey sorry about what I
said earlier
you're really not all that bad in fact I
wanna go get dinner someday no where you
going no oh come on oh come on I finally
work up the courage to ask a beautiful
lady like yourself out on a date never
this role-playing girl bye excuse me
perdón perdón wha this was a waste of
time because I knew I got the wire
cutters I was about the exclamation
point or the question mark was all about
anyway don't know why I even bother why
do I even bother the answer is I don't
know I really don't
oh well but now I have no idea where I'm
supposed to go I really don't there's a
mirror but there's also another door
I think that's wait a minute what about
up that street over there
hang on the street near the beginning
that I didn't go to because there were
too many enemies here and I'm gonna blab
them all I'm gonna blame them
remember in new grounds when uh still as
when voting things downwards Balaam this
piece of crap admit it is so bad it
deserve to be brown I still wonder if
that's a bone there's a freaky deaky
like what happened here I mean obviously
[ __ ] went down with the zombies but I
mean what else happened that caused all
the destruction
I don't even know how this guy is still
alive yeah this is the first alleyway
that I didn't go down because of
whatever maybe that kitty cats back
again you are going to die dead wait a
minute no does me work on these guys
meat doesn't work on these guys right no
meat doesn't work on these guys you are
going to get Blum sir
hope you don't mind bum bum bum and then
you fall down on the floor and I shot
you in them yeah oh I am sorry that you
bled all over oh my there are more of
you than I thought maybe this is why you
gave me so much ammo why have any flares
I do not I have no flares but I have
bunch of car battery and thing um mammy
what you you ignore my booms and bangs
fall to floor and then go die Wow no
don't go die don't die die there you go
you die you die good okay okay you two
you use your gun do that blam Oh get
away no no you fall down you fall down
now and then I blame you ma'am once of a
good measure
alright there we are that's a who's
superflat world what do you mean ah
s/w world that's what it was got it got
it okay I got it
trust Eli it's an arcade game about
illness and death so surgeon simulator
aha can't see straight why not what do
you need needs milk how about some milk
mmm good old milk I was a bad eye
oh that was dumb I shouldn't have done
that
oh I'm gonna drink this soda there we go
much better now all better
ruined it huh I basically am going to
die because of what I did
uh I'm about collecting don't I go hey I
can play wait a minute why does he keep
changing his mind about what to get you
got a bad feeling about this one
old man filled with regret why don't you
be more depressing you douche games oh
hi
where the hell did you come from well
this got disturbing all right then say
what it is you want to say I'm tired of
all this creeping around I have no
information for you I can tell you this
though you may not be ready to learn
anything goodbye what is stop talking in
riddles you said you were gonna tell me
this and then you can fill me where the
hell am i or am I now I'm gonna need to
sleep soon been awake for quite a bit
behind here good good that's all I have
to say about that
good get out of my way her sorry I just
farted
is that why you're walking away from me
just like everybody in my life
they always walk of what el Crab Shack
el crab shack hey why not why not I
don't see why not
I got a lot of health tonics I have
somebody else Amir or
Amir or or I can do a mirror yeah
awesome I can go home now and now I can
stock up on Wawa cuz I put this down
Oh healing water yelling water what why
well I got some pills and what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna take a green pill before
I go to bed and then I'm going to dream
a dreamy dream and dream a box head that
kind of rhymed a little bit green pill
all right forgive me of my
transgressions against the horrifying
zombies maybe the green pill will make
things all better sunshine in rainbows
oh this is not sunshine and rainbows you
must suspect you're not alone now you
even wrote it in your diary didn't you I
may have who are you to say I keep doing
things without realizing it try reading
it then sometimes it's good to remember
what happened I wouldn't come and see me
again for a while if I was you why why
you got it fine for you I'm not even
gonna check the director because I'm not
gonna waste time going to see him or
maybe I should know now this wrong was
you're the mirror
no that's wrong I was gonna I was gonna
go get more ammo no I got plenty
nevermind look deeply into it I don't
really want to stare too long why
because you're suffering from a horrible
victimization of ugly I don't even know
what victimization of ugly means but you
know what I mean
means you're ugly in a fruit salad hey I
like those whoa hey hey hi hey no means
no no means no don't make me I'll use
this I'm gonna blame you I actually
don't see your way around here cuz that
was a 90 spot over there you're ready
get ready all there's a lot of you it
would have believed me to get some sort
well kept doing that is weird man Wow
Wow you should batter blood all over my
face oh this is not good this time
now I'm going to run away cuz this was a
bad idea and I didn't go I didn't go
what a big fountain was slipped Robin mm
root salad
all better I didn't even blame a single
one of them kind of horrible blamer oh
wait no yes I did I got whoa whoa that
was that was the wrong button oh god no
oh no this is how I die I die I die now
I die now let me look at wall as I died
that was a bad idea everybody hold on
everybody hold your horses I don't even
know how to get by him without the gun
so how would I know how to get by him
with the gun why would I be able to do
that not my fault not my fault at all Oh
now no that would be way too much work
that would be way too much ever I was
thinking that I was supposed to trade
the uh supposed to trade the ammo for
flares but then I would have to run to
the director and run to the Hank guy for
the ammo and then would have been back
and forth and that would have been
incredibly way too boring to watch so
I'm just gonna blame all these guys the
right way now in reload make sure I'm
full up on blam OHS what I call him my
blammo pull my blam my Blum with blam oh
it's gone but blam and of lamin eyes
and head shots and shots head shots ow
that really hurt buddy
no BAM that's right um now I'm gonna eat
this victory salad mmm tastes like win
whoosh all better what do they hit me
was i infected oh I didn't feel like I
don't feel infected that's a sound we're
good
what what did I do
what did i do did I do to you
don't make me ma'am will you why did
that one come after me he wasn't after
me before my lights not on weirdo oh
maybe I heard it coming I was supposed
to hide well how was I supposed to know
that what is that what is that I don't
want this Canastota it's gross fine I'll
drink it mine whatever you know what I
don't care I don't care anymore
mmm amazing it was delish
what strange it looks like this building
feels out of place here uh why they sure
are giving me a lot of handgun ammo I
mean honestly whoa what this done with
aina Glen more like a battle took place
I got a bad feeling all of a sudden
something about it creeps me out is this
a work of the survivors I don't know I'm
kind of buff
hey wait a minute don't I remember
seeing a bus a long time ago
I think the electrics are inside that
panel what if I can get it open
how about with the crib air now there's
a use if I ever saw one god it opened
exposed wires well I just happen to have
wire cutters snip so far so good
why is this snip now I can probably
attached them to something oh you mean
like all battery Wow I can't believe I
had all that ha ha ah sweet eye all
right I feel great I did it now I just
hope that I can save soon cuz I've oh
look at this everything is working out
for me everything is working out
beautifully I am so happy gosh life is
was that do you guys see something right
before I went in the right before I went
in the door did I see something
okay all right okay all right I'm gonna
get some crackers let me go to bed fine
you know what I'm just gonna go gonna go
to bed
weird stuffs happening I got a bad
feeling I think I've said that like 19
times and then I'm gonna go back and win
the game don't know how yet but I'm
gonna uh humming doing on my shot a lot
of bullets I I could get more I mean
I've got pills to give the guy I could
get like 53 ammo I might as well you
know I'm right here
never know when I'm gonna need it
because I've been running into more of
these situation with giant pile this is
the trick that I didn't realize that I
could do that I probably could have done
before but didn't do because I am a big
dumb I am the biggest dumb actually
thanks Hank here's some more pills let
us know in the comments below if you
want me to give Hank pills comment rate
and subscribe if you like me giving Hank
Bill's comment rate and subscribe if you
don't like me giving what ok enough ammo
screw you
your Cooper did I gave you one pill one
pill
yeah there we go all right now give me
more give me more
ah all right all right all right all
right another day all right that should
be enough I don't see why it would need
more than 50 although I have a feeling
this game is soon gonna show me why I
need more than 50 oh boy
because my logic behind that is if
someone was playing this game without
killing any any of the optional things
which I'm I'm pretty sure there's always
a way to get around him if if if they
got by all of them then there would have
to be something that you would need all
of those bullets for because it's giving
you bullets it is giving you bullets it
is giving you know they're giving you
bullet weight you're starting to look
like one of them how and why did you get
bit oh the answer is yes a million whoa
that is a skull that is a Scully skull
irma going oh boy what is this place
is this the end of the road what was I
expecting to find I don't know
why was that
okay oh wow wow way from dead space whoa
Jebus are you that thing that I need to
shoot a lot it's all over this time I
know it is dominant Oh run away okay
oh god that's not good lamb-lamb oh god
oh no aah
how much but run away from that how I'm
I'm so dead I'm I didn't even get a
chance how am I supposed to know hey
back in all god that hurt
wow how a game you can't just suddenly
throw combat at me
goodness gracious Oh
the seriously is a very very strange
direction to take this suddenly shove
him into combat and that did look like a
dead space [ __ ] I don't have my ammo I
don't think I'll even do I need more
ammo
that's the question do I need more ammo
you know what can never do with too much
ammo I Monday good night's sleep before
I go to this Amy actually after I get
the ammo I'm gonna try to find that
kiddy and then I'm gonna Pat the kiddy
because I have a feeling that this might
be the end of the game
Hank Hank thank you my papa ah let's not
go into weird roleplay just yet I'm blue
for one clip thanks room and I'll give
you like all of these no I want to keep
some of these for the boss fight I guess
I just need to find the right balance I
don't think we're gonna get through this
I'm not even sure that I'm gonna get
through this so uh you just take it easy
there Bowie dope Bowie dude dude you
know that I'm going out in the streets
why don't you just give me more ammo why
you gotta be a stingy bastard also why
you got to be turning into a zombie why
you gotta be doing that oh they're
looking at slow those huh leave the ball
low but are you little blue just looking
over here then looking over there then
looking over here then walking over
there did someone kill all my friends oh
no no I saw something here okay so I
gotta go find the keyd but I gotta be
very careful about a protein Nakia tea
ah
you
come here kitty uh don't worry about me
we just are normal guy just a cool cat
like you oh yeah don't worry about me
I'm not dangerous
meow indeed oh look at the little kitty
oh that was not worth it
that was not worth that effort I'm
hungry now doesn't it whoa where am i
where I took a wrong turn down her bed
Ellie excuse me just gonna no powder
there go over here oh goodness
that one hurt huh huh my eyes are
watering from that one okay
then I'm going to go save and then I'm
going to go kill me a bot how much fun
oh uh oh yeah that's the diary I'm
supposed to read I need to eat yeah okay
maybe it's time for that delicious ham
I've been saving it this whole game oh I
should probably cook that yeah I should
cook this make this like ceremonial and
all that jazz
well this is it I loved you but I'm
gonna need a cooking oh well then I'm
just gonna eat it screw it you can eat
it raw what's the worst that could
happen what about an eye orange taste it
oddly fresh good fine I guess I don't
get my delicious hey I could've sworn
that I got a pot from the director some
era a pan or something from the director
broth I get more sleep again alright
this is it this is the showdown I've got
my ammo I'm saved up I'm not hungry
I'm gonna go ready to go bring it on
bring it on bring it on I need to just
won him when I'm not when I'm running
away I need to put the gun away let me
just make sure I'm loaded up full of
blammo
get ready they're ready to rock
what is this place end of the road blah
blah blah oh no you bring it bring it
you [ __ ] that must be the sound of that
gate lifting up for some stupid reason I
don't think that oh hi Wow your gun
allow your gun but a lot you're okay
lawyers no don't face that way
how we that heard yeah put dude put it
away put it away put it away and run but
into an Hren and now
shoot shoot him shoot him shoot him back
up a bit back up a few yeah good one
good one Jim that's right run away run
away
I'm resulted all right I'm ready
why are you running hey ain't running go
get back here
get back here going on what's going on
Oh No
who did this to you what can I do
tell me please how can I stop the
bleeding hey kid Oh is the director
don't worry about me
seems I'm finished here foraged a little
too far this time you're not gonna die
on me well it has to happen sooner or
later son
what was it they say sometimes you eat
the bar and forget it exactly it's not
fair why did it have to be you you're my
friend hey you keep your chin up kid
you'll need to do if you're gonna find
her the hospital wait you know or two
who is she
I'm Miss
they're gonna pay for this
whoo wait he's holding something porn
piece of paper just a bunch of numbers
on it
guess what Everly's the end of my
journey but I'm ready for that I know I
am
oh I'm back here now how strange
I'll eat something good can Asuna eat
the whole can just shove it in your
mouth I guess this is the end well
that was a strange boss fight it wasn't
actually that hard I could have just
probably stood there except for the big
snap didn't do much good that's okay
only needed to save because I know
exactly where this coat is gonna be used
the door of the hospital as I walked
through all the bodies that I have left
behind I find myself reflecting on what
I have done to get to this point
everything that I have done to survive
okay
it's gonna be what I'm looking for
there we go all right the standard
hospital information how to escape that
kind of thing nothing unusual about
except the cage of its contents I don't
need it the fires already out fire I
should check out this area first got
some kind of clipboard wait why's my
name on here I was never a patient here
was I anyway looks like it's a room at
the end locked locked locked I hope this
doesn't end with this kid in a coma
locked
locked locked locked locked goodness
gracious
well alright then this must be the room
on the register my room oh wait what's
going on I feel tired all of the sudden
it's a blue pill no I didn't want it
what there's nothing left to do what do
you mean I did I guess hurry no go sleep
elegance you know I think I'm gonna have
a lie down
just for a little while I didn't mean to
take that pill I really didn't
am I gonna die oh where am I now this is
the beginning of the game this place
what's waiting for me this time
I can't skip any more I don't even think
I'm in control no I'm not well let's see
oh you somehow I knew I'd find you here
where else would I be
who are you
it's time to start talking stop laughing
like that who are you yeah who are you
who are you who are you stop it damn it
or I swear to god I'll that's the spirit
show me what kind of man you are
shut up leave me alone
shut up
leave me alone all right I'll make you
shut up once and for all
blam haven't you learned anything yet oh
my oh my you'll have to do better than
that
oh goodness
who what is going on I can't move
okay what oh I'm turning into the old
man oh I see
goodness
how did I get here
nothing makes much sense anymore am i
dead
is this what it feels like
so this is where it ends
are you happy to be here at least
I'd rather be here than anywhere else
we're still together aren't we
oh yeah we are
and there you have it I guess that's it
now the ending that I had didn't quite
make sense but apparently there's a ton
of different endings like I think eight
there's eight different endings
depending on what you did um I I want to
say I want to say this first I really
thoroughly enjoyed this I really did I
wish I had I wish I had done it sooner
like planted a head when I started the
series to do it all at once
um because then I would have been able
to get through her and um I'm not sure
why but less people watch this one than
any other like any of my series ever
like less people fortunately watch this
one but I don't know why because I
really feel like this is a cool game
it's it's got a heart and spirit of like
an old side scroller with its pixel ID
it's meant to look like a CRT uh with
like an old CRT with the big fat pixels
but I mean in all honesty I thought this
was really cool and offered the
exploration of choice in a world that
was just deliciously delightfully
horrific and I I i think i might play
this again on my own you know just
trying to explore the different angles
because i had a lot of fun with it i did
i really had a lot of fun with it not
sure what happened there but this was a
great game i would rate this very highly
in all the games that i've ever
completed this kinda is up there because
i just had a great time with it there's
so much depth to the game that i didn't
get to see because I was you know in a
hurry to finish it to because I was
recording it arose cuz I was talking or
I wasn't thinking situation through it's
not one of the games that you blindly go
through because it was even a parent in
the pacing of the conversation because
there were these long pauses that would
not be necessary in most games um and I
felt like it dragged on a little bit but
it forced you to take things slow and
just sort of appreciate what was there
although it's not perfect game by any
means any stretch of the imagination
there are flaws I felt like it was too
slow in some Birds I felt like the
controls were too restrictive like it's
meant to be slow its that old like
Resident
we'll Silent Hill style I haven't played
so no but I may in the future but
everyone's been asking me to but um I
probably don't don't count on it um but
I mean it's like it's this old drill
that's supposed to feel restrictive
because when the enemies are coming is
supposed to feel panicky and it does do
that but at the same time it feels very
cumbersome there's a good way to
describe it and I'm not sure if it's
perfect I'm not sure if it could have
been any other system maybe it's just
the game as a whole was designed to be
like that and there was no other way to
do it besides that to get the message
across I just felt like something was
detracting from the gameplay just a
little bit but other than that you know
it's overall very good I mean you take
these games as they can obviously
graphically this isn't fantastic in any
way artistically it was great
stylistically great but graphically not
great so that's all I have to say about
that lone survivor was great if I could
recommend it to anyone I recommend it to
anyone who enjoyed this game this
playthrough that I did it's not very
expensive it goes on sale a lot and
played and try to find one of the other
endings that I did not get to because I
actually think that there were some
areas in this excuse me in this game
that I didn't even go to so I'm pretty
sure pretty sure that there's more to
see in this game than I saw so anyway
I'm all done here let me see if I can
get out of this I don't know but I think
I'm done here so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
okay think I remember all the locations
even though they are randomized through
the general pattern to the layout of the
land follow the outside circuit make
sure you hit all the outside location
before going in blender you're here a
little early I am no longer needed
service
ah here we go
whoa this actually explains some stuff
psych report days in treatment whoa
ending blue mental health fee blue path
rank X Oh had a strange dream check the
radio ten times read the diary ones had
a natural healing sleep took the time to
speak to pens IDO took the time to speak
to Kenny talk to G before getting the
gun killed a thin man twenty-seven times
exhausted ninety-eight some okay food
had a green dream received batteries out
of thin air receive foods out of thin
air healed in a green dream hit some
fruit examined the photos obsessively
looked at the chalk drawings visited the
director it some DS not food
ate some warmed real foods left for no
good reason
ate some proper food fired a shot
hundred and forty nine times took a
green pill answered question correctly
in a green dream you mean I could have
answered them correctly spoke to sleepy
cat ate some canned fruit
bad answer in a green dream killed a
helpless fat mean what helpless fat man
they didn't look helpless ate a cracker
ate food that had gone off tortured Hank
with the door I did
what are you talking about asked
insensitive question of Hank in Kurt
encouraged Hank to take more drugs
admitted in knowing the man in blue ate
some food drink obviously bad milk drink
caffeine in the form of fizzy pop answer
the important question directly in the
green green donated Hank some actual
medicine fed the cat shot mother in them
oh-oh-oh
Oh oh my gosh